change
good evening I am Charles overby
president and CEO of the Freedom Forum
and I'm delighted to welcome all of you
here tonight the Freedom Forum is
dedicated to using its resources to
promoting free press free speech and
free spirit
we're the largest organization in the
world that has these freedoms as its
primary mission we're independent
politically and financially we don't
raise money we're here for the long haul
I hope you'll enjoy these facilities
tonight they were built to be the center
of activities for the next 40 years
public opinion about free press and free
speech and free spirit may rise and fall
but these facilities will be here to
stand as a beacon for freedom in good
times and in bad times well into the
21st century the Freedom Forum is what
its name implies a forum for freedom we
work with media experts and the public
at large to advance the mission of
freedom this involves conferences
seminars publications and promotion
across the USA and around the world the
freedom forum tonight is especially
pleased to join with American University
in sponsoring this international
conference on free expression and global
media I'm pleased tonight to be able to
introduce someone who seems to get
almost almost as much on the air TV time
as Mike Wallace for all of you c-span
watchers and who of us is not one you
know that sandy Unger is on his way to
becoming a household word and face as
dean of the School of Communications at
American University sandy is the
moderator of frequent forums sponsored
by American University frequently
carried on c-span
he's not only an educator or he's a
bonafide journalist I'm pleased to
introduce him now welcome sandy Unger
Thank You Charles and thank you to the
freedom forum for joining us in this
very exciting endeavor for several days
now we've been talking about freedom of
expression around the world we've been
joined by courageous journalists from 39
countries by heroes and heroines that we
can all salute and feel honored to be in
their company we're also honored to be
in the company tonight of one of
America's leading journalists the men
it's almost impossible to believe that
for many years the leading television
program top-rated television program in
the United States should be a program
dealing with the news with public
affairs and I think the one person who
has been most important in making that
possible is someone we all admire Mike
Wallace I give you my balls
thank you as sandy said for a few days
now for two and a half three days now at
this ambitious and useful conference
sponsored by the American University
School of Communication and Freedom
Forum you've been exploring the various
barriers to free expression around the
globe and they are formidable barriers
government imposed censorship of course
problems in covering civil wars drug
trafficking the exercise of control over
the media by public and/or private
owners government dictated constraints
on coverage of national security affairs
and for every barrier that you have
discussed one or more of you have
suggested a solution or an end-run but
some problems some barriers are too
difficult to be attacked by handful of
mere journalists when a powerful force
whether an individual or a corporation
or even an entire nation sets out
deliberately to stop an individual
writer or a journalist all writers all
journalists have to respond to the
challenge and what a powerful force sets
out to intimidate a single publisher or
a single broadcast organization all
publishers all broadcasters must be
ready to respond as journalists we are
all of us familiar with a high and
sometimes even fatal cost of sharing our
information and ideas with the public in
the past half century thousands of our
peers have been wounded some of them
killed while trying to report
information from around the world
the statistics are stunning last year
alone 66 foreign correspondents and
local journalists were killed
the highest number recorded by the
Committee to Protect Journalists since
its beginning back in 1981
the first seven months of the Yugoslav
conflict alone saw 19 journalists killed
plus two more missing and presumed dead
the highest rate in modern warfare in
1991 in over a hundred countries 324
journalists were detained a hundred 56
attacked physically 42 expelled from
countries 66 publications of
broadcasters were banned and 27
editorial offices were raided but while
violence against us has taken a high
toll we keep coming back to pursue the
story and by our own collective
persistence we keep the pressure on
so those powerful forces who would
intimidate us become the focus of even
more intense scrutiny but there are
instances when even collective action
may not be enough those in control of an
entire nation state have singled out
individual reporters as they have hunted
found and extinguished them one example
42 years ago CBS correspondent George
Polk shot on ahead in the course of his
reporting on the Greek junta in the four
decades since the violence is not only
not subsided but it is reached to cross
borders and come to us here in America
last month in my hometown New York City
the crusading editor-in-chief of El
Diario Manuel de Dios was murdered
apparently by the drug lords who have
done their best to dominate the politics
of several Latin countries this was the
third killing of a journalist covering
international affairs on US soil in the
past 15 months in 1991 Haitian radio
talk-show hosts Fritz door and
jean-claude Olivier were executed down
in Miami presumably by supporters of
Haiti's current military dictatorship
internationally there are many many
other examples of attempts by
governments to reach out and erratic
individuals were publishing their ideas
or broadcasting their words we all of us
are limited individually in what we can
do for those so persecuted we can listen
carefully to their stories and
regardless of whether we like what they
have said or written published we can of
course make it clear that we support
their right to say it and we can exist
and we can insist that our governments
pressure renegade governments to cease
punishing those who would exercise their
universal right of free expression but
when it comes to the use of violence by
governments to suppress information and
ideas the case of one man stands up
before all others and I am speaking of
course of British author Salman Rushdie
his case is well known but may not be
sufficiently understood let me take a
moment to tell you about it
Salman Rushdie was born to a Muslim
family in Bombay in 1947 schooled in
England became a citizen and by 1988 he
had become an honored member of the
International writing community two of
his novels Midnight's Children and shame
were widely acclaimed but they were
controversial to Midnight's Children was
banned in India shame was banned in
Pakistan he was deemed controversial
also for a short and sympathetic book
about the Sandinista revolution in
Nicaragua
so controversy was not entirely
unexpected when his book The Satanic
Verses first appeared in Britain in
September of 1988 a month later The
Satanic Verses had been banned by the
Indian government under pressure from
Muslim leaders who insisted that two
chapters of that novel which involved a
prophet who is and is not Mohammed were
insulting to Islam and blasphemous to
the Prophet and by the end of that month
every country or city
the world with a sizable Muslim
population at scene angry protests and
then in February of 89 the publication
of the American edition of Rushdie's
novel brought new dimension to the
controversy first it was greeted by a
wave of violent protests in Bombay
Kashmir and Dhaka on February 12 2000
the US Embassy in Islamabad and
Pakistani police opened fire at least
five persons were killed more than a
hundred injured the next day that seems
televised around the world On February
14th in Tehran the late Ayatollah
Khomeini issued a religious edict a
fatwa calling on Muslims everywhere to
kill Salman Rushdie and his publishers
on the following day thousands of
protesters stoned the recently reopened
British Embassy in Tehran and then a
senior Iranian cleric a funny son si who
heads the June 5th foundation promised a
bounty of three million dollars to any
Iranian and the million dollars to any
foreigner who would kill Rushdie in the
three years since Salman Rushdie has
lived underground protected by Scotland
Yard Special Branch
despite his repeated attempts to repair
relations with the Islamic world through
an apology for offending Islam and
despite diplomatic protests to Tehran
the fatwa has repeatedly been renewed in
October of 1990 the United Kingdom
renewed diplomatic relations with Iran
on the expectation that the fatwa would
be lifted but despite additional
international diplomacy it has not been
lifted and so Salman Rushdie remains
underground beside the threat to Rushdie
the American publishing community itself
had been intimidated from issuing a
paperback edition of his novel until
just two weeks ago when an anonymous
consortium
representing we are told most us
publishers announced that it would
publish the paperback edition of The
Satanic Verses however as the Washington
Post's pointed out editorially just
yesterday all was not bravery leading up
to the paperbacks publication here in
the United States the Post wrote
consortiums in Germany Italy France and
other places have banded together names
and all as a way to spread the risk but
still array themselves in public against
transcontinental bullying apparently
there was a similar plan for the United
States names and all that fell apart
when several of the major players
declined to get involved so instead of
publishers and others putting their
mouths where their money is they decided
to hind to hide behind a consortium of
anonymity in the United States
I first met Salman Rushdie about 18
months ago when I interviewed him in a
secret place for 60 minutes it'd been a
hostage of his fart Worthen for 20
months now it has been 38 months 3 long
and painful years but rather than have
me tell you more of his story I suggest
that you listen to the man whose life I
have been describing and then we can
best decide how we should each of us
deal individually and together with such
an extraordinary and lingering threat to
free expression Salman
okay
so what am I doing here well I need to
start off with I would of course I must
thank my hosts and everybody who helped
to make this trip possible which was not
a simple matter what I'd like to do is
to start by asking you to think about
that lack of simplicity for a moment and
just to remind yourself how very odd it
is for a writer interested in human
rights and freedom of expression to
accept an invitation to speak at a
conference like this should be a simple
matter it should not be necessary for
travel plans to be shrouded in secrecy
security forces should not need to pay
me any special attention none of this
should be happening in quite this way
feels a little bit doesn't it like being
inside one of those science-fiction
yarns in which the president gets
unaccountably altered so that all of a
sudden that the Inquisition appears in
Piccadilly Circus and there are witch
burnings on the Potomac it feels a
little like living in the twilight zone
there was a saying that was popular in
the days of the hippie days of the 1960s
it seems appropriate now it run do not
adjust your mind there is a Fault in
reality well the fat bar of imam
khomeini bent the world out of shape
ancient blood lusts were unleashed armed
with state-of-the-art modern technology
battles that we thought didn't need to
be forced anymore battles about ideas
such as blasphemy and heresy which
throughout human history have been the
stormtroopers of bigotry were reenacted
in our streets many people who should
have known better try to defend the real
and the threatened violence and blamed
its victims even now in Britain there is
a powerful lobby which quite regularly
describes me as a person of no value
and I do not exaggerate when I say that
the power of this Lobby is so great that
I am no longer certain of the commitment
of the British authorities to protecting
me I do not say this lightly I do not
say it without reasons I am no longer
certain of the commitment of the British
authorities to the task of protecting so
I say again there is a fault in reality
do not adjust your minds what has been
done to the Satanic Verses its author
its publisher translators and
booksellers is one of the great crimes
against freedom of recent years the
novel is not the crime the author is not
the criminal it's time to say that this
miscarriage of justice cannot continue
the peculiar evil of silencing the
expression of an opinion is that it is
robbing the human race posterity as well
as the existing generation robbing those
who dissent from the opinions still more
than those who hold it for if the
opinion is right they are deprived of
the opportunity of exchanging error for
truth if wrong they lose what is almost
as greater benefit the clearer
perception and livelier impression of
truth produced by its collision with
error those some of you may have
recognized those not my words they come
from John Stuart Mill's great essay on
Liberty it is extraordinary how much of
Mills essay applies directly to the case
of the Satanic Verses the demand for the
burning of this novel and the indeed the
eradication of its author is precisely
what Mill called the assumption of
infallibility those who make such
demands do so just as mill anticipated
because they find the book and its
author immoral and impious but he writes
this is the case of all others in which
the assumption of infallibility is most
fatal these are exactly the occasions on
which the men of one generation commit
those dreadful mistakes which excite the
astonishment and
horror of posterity he gives two
examples of such occasions the cases of
Socrates and of Jesus Christ - these can
be added a third case bout of Galileo
all three men in all three cases the
accusation was blasphemy and heresy
all three were attacked by the
stormtroopers of bigotry and yet as is
playing to anyone they are the founders
of the philosophical moral and
scientific traditions of the West we can
say therefore that the process is known
as blasphemy and heresy far from being
the greatest of Evil's are the methods
by which human thought has made some of
its most vital advances the writers of
the European enlightenment knew this
they all came up against the
stormtroopers at one time or another and
it was because of his nervousness of the
power of the church not the power of the
state that Voltaire suggested that it
was advisable for writers to live in
close proximity to a frontier so that if
necessary they could hop across it into
safety frontiers will not defend a
writer now not if this new form of
terrorism terrorism by remote-control
terrorism by edict and bounty is allowed
to have its day
this form of terrorism is an exercise of
power and religious persecution is never
a matter of morality and always an
exercise of power to defeat these
modern-day witch burnings it is
necessary to show them that our power to
is great it is necessary to show them
that our numbers are greater than that
and that our resolve to is greater than
theirs this is a battle of wills The
Satanic Verses was published in the
United States soon after the fall and
early 1989 that's just about three years
ago during that period its publishers
and booksellers have been subjected to
enormous very menacing pressures and
they have stood firm at times they have
wobbled a little as who would not as I
myself certainly have from time to time
but the book has been kept in print it
is in print today and for that act of
principle and courage I thank his Viking
penguin and all the other publishers
around the world I thank American
Booksellers all the individual men and
women who have participated in this in
difficult circumstances what needed to
be done was done but we didn't finish
the job we did not complete the cycle of
publication we did not publish a
paperback edition in the first two years
after the hardback was published I had a
number of conversations with the senior
executives of Penguin Books even a few
rather absurdly arranged
cloak-and-dagger meetings of the type
that Mike Wallace will remember I told
them in those meetings that in my
opinion it was absolutely necessary to
publish a paper back not only in order
to demonstrate that we had not yielded
to threats but because the most normal
thing to do was in fact also the safest
thing not to publish was to show fear
and to show fear was to invite further
attacks Penguin Books took a different
position they continued to support the
idea of paperback publication
when the time was right but in those
tens times they could never agree that
the time was right please understand I
do not blame them for taking a different
view from mine they had their
considerations including the safety of
their staff I had mine
they followed a period in which for
reasons I've gone into before I also
agreed to suspend the paperback edition
in the hope that the space created would
make possible explanations and
reconciliations this was a mistake
and it didn't happen finally recognizing
the mistake I said at Columbia
University last winter that the baked
Bach had waited long enough and should
be published you may ask why bother why
not forget about it
so let me just quickly restate the
reasons first there can be no question
that the Satanic Verses would have been
published in paperback probably about a
year after its original hardback
publication had it not been for the
threat saying against it
non publication would therefore be a
great defeat for freedom of expression
it would demonstrate that violence is
capable of determining in present-day
America and Britain and the rest of the
english-language market what books can
be published and in what form we have
done so much to withstand pressure we
cannot and we must not fall at the final
hurdle second the way publishing is now
constituted in the English language
countries paperback publication is
simply the only way of guaranteeing long
term availability it is already the case
that a hardcover copy of the Satanic
Verses can be very hard to find in your
local bookstore in a few years it will
disappear altogether and then in effect
the book will have been banned and
everything that has been done and
suffered will have been done and
suffered for nothing what a defeat that
would be
third The Satanic Verses is a book that
has been very largely condemned on read
it remains my view that the text itself
is the best defense that the majority of
fair-minded readers given the chance to
read it would find that the charges
leveled against it are utterly
unmolested false
I want that text available too as wider
readership as possible the attacks on it
after all have been trumpeted to an
incredibly and incredibly wide audience
all around the world I don't have the
ability to shout as loud as that but I
can try and make sure that people are
not excluded from making up their own
minds about the book because they can't
afford the cost of a hardback novel
students must read The Satanic Verses if
only because for the very worst of
reasons it has become an important text
scholars must read it and young Muslims
and atheists and lovers of literature
lovers of literature perhaps above all
finally this is a somewhat personal
perhaps emotional viewpoint I am proud
of my book like a parent I am appalled
by what has been said about my child I
can't help feeling that if you were to
get to know it you might like it better
but also that to leave the paperback
unpublished would be to accept in some
degree that it is indeed a bad child
that should be consigned to some sort of
limbo to leave the paperback unpublished
would be to pass a guilty verdict on an
innocent book there is something I want
to say about this question of the
paperback tonight after my visit to
Columbia I had one last meeting with
penguin books at a location in England
at that meeting I was told that they
felt unable to agree to my request to
publish a paper back edition indeed they
said they could see no moment in the
future when they would be able to
publish it was a friendly and sorrowful
meeting I thanked them for their
continuing support of the hardback
edition and said that in the light of
what they told me I had no alternative
but to ask them to return the
english-language paperback rights in the
book and this they did since that time
many people have been looking into the
ways and means of completing with great
difficulty what ought never to have been
a difficult task that work has now borne
fruit so it is a great delight to have
the opportunity of making this
announcement before an audience which
will I'm sure appreciate its importance
it has been a long road and a road beset
with problems but I am now able to speak
a sentence which I often thought would
never be spoken today ladies and
gentlemen is the publication day of the
paperback
it's it there is rather emotional
moments there it there it is a lot of
people have worked very hard to make
this possible they've given their advice
and their time and their skills and
mostly free of charge and alas the best
thing I'm able to do for them at the
moment is to leave them unnamed but they
know who they are and I take them for
this and I hope I hope that once this
book is in the shops and people can see
that there it is and nobody's rushing in
to do terrible things to people people
may be willing to own up to the fact
that they helped bring this book into
being I hope that will happen
that was worth crossing the Atlantic for
but there are actually there are
actually other reasons and I wouldn't
like simply to end on that because I've
also here to suggest to you and beyond
you to the people in this town who run
the world that this matter is not simply
a matter simply a foreign issue in which
American interests and the principles
upon which the United States has been
built are not involved I believe they
are involved and I would like to suggest
that those interests and principles have
already been gravely threatened by what
has happened and failing a solution will
undoubtedly be threatened further the
free society is by its nature and
divided society it is argumentative
multiple plural quarrelsome societies in
motion free societies are societies in
motion and with motion comes tension and
friction free peoples strike sparks and
those sparks are the best evidence of
the existence of freedom totalitarian
societies by contrast seek to halt the
most
of society the snuff out the sparks the
primary purpose of unfreedom is always
to shackle the mind now the creative
process you know is actually quite like
the process of a free society that's to
say within the artists mind many
attitudes many views of the world jostle
and conflict and strike sparks and it is
out of that multiplicity that the work
of art is born this multiplicity is
often been very difficult for artists to
bear let alone to explain Denis Diderot
spoke of the dispute within him between
atheistic materialist rationalism and
his profound need for spiritual and
moral depth he said it infuriates me to
be enmeshed in a devilish philosophy
which my mind is forced to accept but my
heart to disown Dostoevsky also agonized
about the coexistence in his heart of
absolute faith and absolute unbelief and
Milton you remember was described by
Blake Milton that devout genius who
Blake thought was better at describing
hell than heaven in Paradise Lost was
described by Blake as being because he
was a poet naturally of the devil's
party within every artist perhaps within
every human imagination there exists to
paraphrase Blake a marriage between
heaven and hell the Satanic Verses is a
novel about that marriage about the
conflicts and tensions between but also
within the religious and the secular
view of the world it is the profoundly
ironic fate of this novel and of its
author to the engulfed by exactly the
war of realities that it seek to
describe and to comprehend
I want to come to a difficult point
which is why am I in America talking
about this I would say this the Satanic
Verses was and is an American
publication the principal contract for
the book was signed in New York the
attack on it therefore was it is an
attack not only on my right to write
freely but also on the right of an
American publisher to publish freely and
perhaps most important of all on the
rights of American readers to decide
what they want to read because
censorship is also an assault on readers
as has been suggested even before the
for the fact whether the United States
information service building in Pakistan
was attacked the United States has been
at the center of this affair from the
beginning on the 21st of February 1989
President Bush said inciting murder and
offering rewards for its perpetration
are deeply offensive to the norm of
civilized behavior two days later a
letter from members of the House of
Representatives respectfully requested
the president quotes that the government
of Iran be put on public notice that it
is the United States intention to
postpone indefinitely any possibility of
normalized trade or diplomatic relations
until the threats have been rescinded
and the safety of the author publishers
and sellers of The Satanic Verses has
been assured that safety ladies and
gentlemen has not yet been assured the
American publishers
and sellers have to have been menaced
you know about the beginning book shops
and newspaper in the Bronx book shops in
California a newspaper Bronx were
firebombed the protests have of course
continued US ambassador Nicholas Billy
ot is the president of the Association
of American publishers testified at a
special hearing before the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee that quotes
any real concession to terrorists
baguettes more terrorism meanwhile the
threats have continued the bounty money
has been increased so
time's British intelligence has had
reports of death squads financed
directly by the Iranian government the
Italian translator has been knifed the
Japanese translator murdered the fatwa
is being implemented the British
government now says now once now that
the British hostages are all free
the British government now says that
this matter is at the top of its agenda
and that relations with Iran will not be
normalized until a satisfactory solution
has been reached
115 members of the European Parliament's
that's a large majority have passed a
strong resolution condemning the threats
there are increasingly loud demands
throughout Europe that this matter be
speedily resolved the US government's
voice would add immeasurably to the
weight of those demands just to deal
with one or two objections it is
regularly suggested by Iranian
politicians that the fatwa is
irreversible
but the problem is therefore incapable
of solution this is untrue Thoth bars
have been reversed fairly regularly but
let's start one step back from that for
a start the offers of money for people's
assassination are quite plainly secular
matters in this case the Iranian
government can't even attempt to hide
behind this theological smokescreen
these so-called bounty offers must be
publicly effectively unaccountably
repudiated by Iran international law is
also a matter for governments Iran's
attempt to export this most lethal
aspect of its revolution beyond its own
jurisdiction is also a matter in which
no theological considerations apply Iran
has repeatedly stated its respect for
international law and its wish to adhere
to such law it is time for this respect
and this desire to be demonstrated
but even according to Islamic theology
there are certainly ways for thought was
to be canceled there's one vivid example
in the FIR meny period an extremely
unpopular fatwa that was passed banning
or cigarette smoking and tobacco
products that only lasted a year the
grand ayatollahs have the power to
cancel the front part and they must be
encouraged to do so Iran's own
Constitution contains an interesting
legal principle which that the name is
mus la hat which translates roughly as
self-interest a principle which was put
there by Imam Khomeini himself and
according to it any Iranian laws
including laws based on Quranic texts
can be abrogated if they run counter to
the national interest of Iran the point
then is to demonstrate to Iran that the
fatwa does indeed run counter to Iranian
interests and must therefore like any
law the point to mention is that since
Khomeini's status in Iran was that of
Nohr giver his fatwas were simply laws
so like any law the fatwa can be
repealed it is also as many learned
Islamic jurists have pointed out illegal
according to Islamic law now of course
I'd either live under nor accept Islamic
law but the Iranian authorities do
example Imam Khomeini was a Shia my big
background is sundy Muslim he should
therefore have no jurisdiction over me
again he lived in the Islamic world the
so-called house of Islam while I do not
Islamic law disqualifies itself from any
authority outside the house of Islam
again the condemnation was made without
any attempt to study the text without
any pretense a due process of law and it
is therefore by Islamic standards
invalid I mean I'm here to say what you
would expect me to say the case of the
Iranian fatwa against the Satanic Verses
must be closed
it affects American business interests
the safety of American citizens the
principles of freedom embodied in the
American Constitution now a paperback
edition of the book has finally been
published published in part to uphold
the principles enshrined in the First
Amendment it is more than ever
imperative that the United States in
concert with Britain and Europe and
other countries act to defend those who
have had the courage
to complete this much menaced
publication terrorist techniques become
popular when there seem to be working
airplane hijacking the taking of
hostages became can custom when it
seemed to be burying political fruit it
ceased when it seemed not to be bearing
fruit if this new form of terror
this I call remote control terrorism by
edict and bounty is not defeated now any
nation any organization with the
resources to do so
can and will repeat the exercise today
it's me tomorrow it could be you
so there's another reason that's those
eyes well let's say the American reasons
for asking America the cut America to
come on board but I think there are
others for asking the United States to
come on board one is to demonstrate to
the government of Iran and to many other
nations particularly Muslim nations in
which writers are still being harassed
and tortured and killed with depressing
regularity that the United States will
not turn a blind eye to such behavior
Britain Europe the United States all say
these days that human rights will be an
issue in their relationships for the
rest of the world well here's an
opportunity you know to to put their
money where their mouth is finally
however the point about asking the
United States to help is quite
straightforwardly and and unidentified
States is able to help because these
days the power and influence of the
United States is so great that a Candie
of absolute and invaluable assistance in
a struggle in which the Friends of
freedom cannot contemplate defeat so I
appeal to the American government to
show itself to be the true friend of
Liberty in a world in which that high
ideal has acquired of late many powerful
enemies thank you
I'm Scott Armstrong and I'm responsible
for many of the minor indignities who
are forced to suffer tonight to get here
a small portion of those that sallman
suffers on a daily basis
saman has agreed to take some questions
I'm going to be up here to be a
timekeeper and at an arbitrary point
I'll be rude to you and he'll depart us
can I have the first question Mike this
is the water prerogative someone what
would you what would you like the United
States government here the White House
and the Congress to do well I I put I
suggested just now a few of the things
that I felt that they were that they
might be able to consider but um well
the truth is that I had I that's
precisely a question that I had one of
the reasons for crossing the Atlantic
that coming particularly to Washington
was that I had hoped to be able to
discuss that question with various
members of the Senate and the House of
Representatives in particular but for
reasons that frankly I'm not clear about
that meeting has not taken place and has
been cancelled what's their remaining
schedule yes there was yes there was and
I was informed that it would not take
place I'm really I don't know why so
it's it's some difficult to explain
enjoyed from where for well let's say
during my visit
come on can you identify yourself with
your eyes if you write a newspaper now
we'll live in the United States visiting
professor at the University of Minnesota
mr. rushdy it goes without saying that
we admire your courage
we admire your fight for freedom of
speech freedom of the human being but at
the same time I would like to say one
thing I came from the country we are
thousands of writers artists scientists
we are killed short arrested exiled
tortured nobody defended then there we
are know who detective forces shielding
them very inaud President of the United
States and Congress helping them they
didn't publish their books because books
we are killed as the authors were killed
here even in this room are
representatives of the journalistic
forces of South Africa chili salad or
Russia again who just came from prisons
they don't compare themselves with
Galileo with some novice they don't
compare themselves with Jesus Christ
disability but when but at the same time
very there are unsung heroes of the
noble fight for freedom of the press
freedom of steps of speech you dedicated
your speech almost entirely to your case
to your book you told us that today the
paperback publication of your book is
already launched we are very happy about
it we congratulate you but please taking
the account that you are not alone in
this fight
that you are not there may be utmost
case because if we compare studied with
how many how many looks very small very
insignificant if we compare how many
with other dictators personal and extra
my question is please be one of us well
I think it's some thank you for your
there was I suppose a question mark at
the end of that so thank you for your
question I find it extraordinary to have
to defend myself in this situation
I've spent my life a great deal of my
life as a writer protesting about the
conditions of writers in other countries
sir and I think perhaps anybody who
knows about that would know that I'm not
trying to compare myself to Galileo and
Socrates of Christ I'm trying to point
out that when people are attacked for
blasphemy so were the greatest figures
in European Western history I'm not
trying to I mean why is that is that an
inner feeling and inadmissible statement
in your view is that incorrect no all
right
of course many people are worse off than
me I tried to mention in the speech a
reason why I wanted people's support was
to say this is simply the most visible
case in the Islamic world I'm sorry
that's it that's it is I don't think
many people would deny that I tried to
point out that Iran has been killing its
writers for years I've pointed out to
journalists for the last two days more
or less non-stop that even in in
moderate Islamic countries like Egypt
writers have been rounded up in jail for
terrible sentences at the moment so I
mean I'm sorry I don't defend myself for
making my own case maybe you've never
heard of what I've said before so but
perhaps you should find out zoom a bit
and anything that do we have a
translator from Susilo
what the Lila versus a panic it can give
the down-home feel less than a gallon
calm down
you see a piggy vision on your book
Satanic Verses is forbidden in my
country of Senegal as it is in many
other countries 60 people if you dated
Google Caracas you need a manifest
assume a fundamental decision
the reason was to avoid the trouble that
would have been caused by fundamentalist
demonstration cd-rom kuvvatov Raj a
considered a humanist on September
therefore your work is considered as a
threat in many countries
Estela de Vaudreuil vu+ KCM la pena care
upon days as I keep on scholarly Burkett
expression no vampire confirmed a big
Laplace family as you saw Sarah Ramirez
so I'd like to post two questions to you
the first is what do you say to people
who think that liberty and freedom of
expression are not to be confused with
blasphemy do them cos you know a great
evil part of what increased the Roma
don't let people Acacio I couldn't you
can up an accordion a pail of water
would attend Cujo Condon I'm sorry of
July could you repeat says yes
did I do I regret parental which has led
to a condemnation to that
well the question of class for me the
first question I know as I tried to say
and I'll so I'll say it again the
accusation of blasphemy is always the
accusation used in totalitarian
religious states to prevent new ideas I
mean it's well known that the Egyptian
writer Mahfouz the winner of the Nobel
Prize was accused of blasphemy it's well
known that within the last decade groups
of prominent Saudi clerics have declared
the entire project of modernism as being
blasphemous and that any writer with
blasphemed with modernistic tendencies
has been accused of blasphemy in this
country I think there's an excellent
principle which is that there is no such
law as a law against blasphemy I would
support the abolition of such laws
everywhere in the world
that's the question joy second question
was do I regret writing the book because
of what happened to it well I certainly
regret a great deal of what happened I
mean I much prefers I said not to have
to live in this very bizarre situation
but it's impossible to regret a book
unless one disavows the ideas in it and
I do not do that
sorry nobody's translating to the
Gentiles who doesn't understand deeply
also he does sorry oh good right well I
mean the answer is I think but inside
this book is the answer to your question
no I do not believe there to be in this
book any insult or offense the people
the demonstrations that happened the
bannings that happened in every instance
happen before the book had ever entered
the country the book was bound in India
before any copy of it had ever reached
India was bound unread the book was
banned in South Africa and I will be
willing to bet a lot of some money in
Senegal before anybody had read it to
make a determination about what was in
it I find it difficult to accept the
blame for the banning of a book that was
banned without it having been perused
yeah Daniel Shaw of National Public
Radio this diversity can you say a
little more about why you feel less than
completely secure with British
protection and whether you're
considering then living in some other
country perhaps this one no I'm not
considering living in any other country
I'm a British citizen and I intend to
live in Britain the problem is that I as
I mentioned earlier that there is a kind
of conservative polemic against the
protection that takes place in England
and I think that's beginning to have an
effect on the authorities responsible
for the protection that's to say there's
a there's a sense in which I mean as the
judge went over there pointed out I
would I would like to be told by a
policeman the other day that plenty of
people live in England in danger and
some of them get killed that didn't
strike me as a reason for for ceasing to
protect somebody who who might get
killed but there we are there is that
there is a problem I think there's a
lack or a diminishing will to continue
with this I don't think anybody had ever
expected this to go on such a long time
I don't know I don't know well we'll
find out hopefully at the general
election Gerry Dan Smith CBS News mister
rusty let me pursue this matter of the
cancelled meeting and therefore American
policy within the limits of your
security can you tell us with whom you
were going to me what reason if any was
given for the cancellation of the
meeting and finally whether there is any
recourse or approach to the White House
well I have actually perhaps I should
ask stop you want to talk about that I'm
not exactly sure who there was that I
was getting to to meet I mean I know one
or two names arriving I don't know
whether I should mention them I don't I
have not been given any convincing
reason for the cancellation I'm sorry
legislators legislators of both houses
but during
the cherry freedom the freedom forum I
was going to ask the similar sort of
question maybe a Scott can help us on it
did was a meeting requested with the
executive branch members in the United
States as Terry is suggesting someone
other than the Congress and if so was
I'd also cancelled as I understand it
the meeting was going to be with members
of the Senate and the House of
Representatives that's what I that's
what I understand and and the
cancellation was very abrupt and I have
not had a satisfactory reason for it
getting gay take a microphone if you are
if you had it to do over again sort of a
follow-up to the other questioner would
you do it differently how would you do
it I don't know I you know it's very
difficult for me when I began writing
for Satanic Verses it was nine years ago
when I finished writing Satanic Verses
was four years ago
that's to say I am already substantially
different as a writer from the person
who wrote the book if I were if I were
to settle down to treat that subject now
I would clearly write it differently if
I was to write any one of my novels now
I wouldn't write it the same way I would
not write Midnight's Children the same
way no I have to say that I I would like
to think I mean if you're asking the
impossible question that if I had known
then what would happen would I have done
it you know and I would like to be able
to say yes sure I'd have written it
exactly the same way every sentence and
so forth because I mean that you know
that's as it were the correct answer I
didn't realize I really don't know I
suspect I might not have been quite as
heroic as that true human journalism
student at American University but mr.
Rushdie how is your creative process
you're writing been affected by the fat
boy and your deal can you still create
yeah it's it's but it's more difficult I
mean simply because the the time
available is is is is polluted by by
having to constantly think about things
I shouldn't have to think about like
like this like this affair I
I have managed to continue writing I
published Haroon in the sea of stories I
published a volume of essays imagining
home lines and and you know for me to
publish two books in three years as a
kind of world's record because I'm
usually a lot slower than that so I so
have managed to go on I mean I think
there's no doubt that it's true to say
that the task of beginning a major novel
has been has been harder and I mean I am
now finally trying to begin one but um I
don't know I think it'll probably take a
longer time so I slowed down even more
on first first year Gotham Adhikari The
Times of India above me was I think I
should make one correction the
Midnight's Children mr. Wallace was not
banned in India yeah but did you find it
especially ironic that the first country
to ban your book was a non-islamic one
and and the country that you were born
it yes I do I've always found that one
of the one of the saddest things that it
began in India I also find it very sad
the way the garden India I mean what
what happened was that one journalist in
India today wrote one article it was
based on an interview would be which
added to its and added to this article
work were several were taught several
two or three quotes from the novel which
were chosen for maximum impact let's say
and and on the basis of that one article
a couple of Muslim MPs the next day made
a made a stink about the novel
threatened the wobbly that then very
wobbly Rajiv Gandhi government with with
all sorts of public gum disorder and the
government um chicken diet and banned
the book without even bothering to
acquire a copy I mean I thought that was
very sad and I did say so in open
letters to the prime minister at that at
the time all I can hope is that if India
was the place where it began it might
also be the place where it begins to end
it would be it would be nice for India
to be the first country in the world to
lift the ban of the Satanic Verses
Khanh I've come from Pakistan from your
address it seems that you you feel
danger to your security from from Iran
only I've come from Pakistan and I
believe there are dozens of people who
definitely have not written or will want
to get you and kill you and that's not
stand correct for Pakistan I believe
there are lots of people in Bangladesh
and and India how can you expect
security from the United States from all
of those people in all those countries
is I don't think that's only the problem
from Iran well thanks for the
information there is a there is a there
is a difference you see between what
you're talking about and what I'm
talking about there's no question there
are plenty of individuals who for
various reasons if they were to come
across me might not wish to shake me by
the hand there's a difference between
that and and the issue of
state-sponsored professional terrorists
why don't expect I don't think anybody
could reasonably expect the British
government or any other government in
concert with the British government to
persuade all the people in the world who
don't like me that they should like me a
lot we don't think that's a political
process I do think it's legitimate to
ask the governments of the free world to
say that if they wish to to do business
with and to readmit into world society a
government such as Iran that they can
make a precondition of that that that
government ceases to finance
international terrorism their own that's
the point is that if you're asking me
whether I can look out for the odd
hooligan who might decide to have a go
at me I'm prepared to take that on what
I what I'm not able to take on is
dealing personally as a private citizen
with the issue of international
terrorism
anton harbour from the wheat e-mail in
johannesburg on a newspaper that invited
you to south africa month after you
published the book you are unfortunately
unable to come but I do before I ask my
question I'd like to say that it's an
invitation would like to renew as soon
as you find it convenient would be happy
to host your visit there thank you my
question is what is your attitude now to
the religion Islam well I mean all right
let me answer this straightforwardly
when I wrote the Satanic Verses I was
actually quite sympathetic towards it
but I think one of the one of the great
ironies about this isn't the Satanic
Verses as a novel almost all of whose
major characters are British or Indian
Muslims not all of whom are portrayed as
wonderful people but I mean but there's
a they're portrayed as human beings in
the world of the book is portrayed from
that point of view I have to say that
after three years of having my life
smashed apart by the forces of religion
and perhaps slightly less well disposed
towards hiding hiding Carter you have
detailed the hiccuping of politicians
and governments and the on-again
off-again willingness of the publishing
industry to put its mouth where its
principles say they are I'm interested
in what the reaction has been
individually and organizationally by
journalists and writers and whether that
has been particular eyes by let us say
within the West whether within the West
it has been subdivided as well has there
been a uniform support or what well I
mean nothing is ever a hundred percent I
you know that there have certainly been
writers who have not been supportive but
I do think that if one's looking at at
communities of support that the support
from writers and intellectuals around
the world has prob and journalists has
probably been the most consistent and
the most consistently positive of any
group that one can think of you know so
so while there have been some exceptions
that I you know that there's an away no
point in naming um that the great
majority of people have been
instinctively supported
Oh sustain well yeah I mean you know
again it's it's always possible to say I
wish people had done more you know but
but actually writers organizations civil
rights organizations human rights
organizations have probably been more
consistent more sustained at keeping
this case in front of the world's
attention than any other groups so
certainly more than political parties
for example Erik Mulder I'm with the
Seattle Times you are I'd like to pursue
a couple of questions one that was asked
earlier and yeah I don't still don't
have it clear whether you've talked with
anybody at the White House or the state
of your US State Department to intervene
for your help and also whether or not
you found any means
perhaps through intermediaries or
something like that to communicate with
the government of Iran itself you know
the US government seem to be able to do
that during the worst of times well as
regards the White House in the State
Department now I've had no I've had no
contacts directly with them as regards
Iran I mean no I'm not in close personal
touch but there were they're having to
were some interesting developments I
mean for example in in London on the on
the day of the third anniversary of the
fog part though as there was suddenly an
invitation from the Iranian mission in
London to Francis de souza of article 19
who runs the Defense Committee there to
come and meet I mean this was after a
long period in which they'd refused to
answer telephone calls or letters
suddenly on that day when there was a
great series of demonstrations in London
they if they had a meeting now I mean
the meeting wasn't wasn't exactly I'd
say a meeting of minds but I mean on the
other hand the fact that it occurred was
significant because in the previous
three years all attempts to make such
contact where were very
straightforwardly rebuffed as regards
over the contact through the British
government there clearly they clearly
are taking place
I mean I'm occasionally given some
information as to what kind of what kind
of conversations have been had
and I mean I would I would hope that
they'll bear fruit and I think the fact
is that but that the political pressure
that has been building around this case
since really since the the the freeing
of the last of the hostages has
stiffened the resolve the British
government somehow I mean did to some
degree and one has to hope the DUP will
bear fruit so I think we are now down to
an issue of political negotiation really
and the question is is how is how tough
the British with European and American
support will be in in making sure that
the that the threats are removed some of
the Tigris will hold it the book phone
and phone yeah right here
okay random causes Ukraine first of all
I want to congratulate you is there
issue of your paper breath and then it
won't ask your question if you're
considering any possibility to print
your book outside of the US is the
contrast where it is not banned for
example in the Soviet Union oh well I
don't I I didn't think that was anywhere
called the Soviet Union well I mean I
believe that there is an illegal pirated
edition in in Russia I haven't seen it
but I've told that it's there I have no
idea what the quality of the translation
is as regards the other countries I've
you know I'm open to offers it would be
very nice if publishers would do it live
in favor of that a Victor Navasky from
the nation over here I live it I have a
three-part question the students of the
publishing industry have been alarmed as
you know at the concentration
conglomerate ization the transnational
publishing community and I wonder first
whether that is affected in a positive
or negative way your situation second
I'm curious with a Viking penguin if you
can say you may not be able to as part
of the consortium and third when the
rights were turned over to you a
technical question did they turn over
the mass-market paperback rights and if
so would you be amenable to an
arrangement whereby the Freedom Forum
was some other publicly minded First
Amendment oriented entity published the
mass-market paperback and took the
publishers share and dedicated it to
promoting some of the ideas that have
been discussed for three days here and
that you could talk about this evening
oh right well I think oh well I'm happy
to like you they tried out you know I
think the correct choice and I was
talked to by agent
but I did pray in principle of Corti
Dave what penguin did was to revert to
me world English language paperback
rights so I mean in that sense I have
them all however I should say that this
organization the consortium Inc is the
is the consortium to which I have given
those paperback rights so any other for
publication would have to be also by
negotiation with them as regards whether
penguin are a member of the consortium
or not well I think you should probably
ask them but I wouldn't tell your breath
oh um I don't know I think you could
argue that both ways I mean I think
there's I think there's no doubt that
the the fact that penguin were a very
large and powerful international company
certainly helped them withstand the
weight of the attack that came against
them I think you know many sense and
many times I believe that if it be into
a small independent publishing company
that had faced that kind of assault they
might well not have been able to I will
not have had the resources to deal with
that so I think that's you know if you
like in favor I mean on the other side I
think it's possible to argue that for
example the the issue of the paperback
or has was was really a political issue
in Britain to a much greater extent than
in the United States and yet the fact
that it's publisher the owner of world
english-language rights was a publisher
in both markets made them reluctant to
publish in fact about anywhere in the
world because of the problem in the
United Kingdom so so there in a sense
the American paperback publication was
if you like delayed because of a problem
in another country so I mean I say you
know I think there's been a prop there's
been an advantage and a disadvantage so
it's a draw
mr. Rushdie Solly with WJLA TV here in
Washington I don't know that any of us
many of us could really understand what
it's like to live on a day to day basis
in hiding with a total lack of freedom
what is your life like now after three
years underground on the day-to-day
basis and is there anyone is there
anything that you hate because of that
well right right notes it's didn't the
question what my life is like I mean
right this moment is getting a bit
better I mean this is a lot more people
that I usually hang out with so I don't
it certainly my my plan to do this a
whole lot more um I mean I do think
they're having to be serious I do I do
think there comes a time when you can't
go on living in a box that I've said
that before and I'd say again I'm going
to do what I can to reclaim ordinary
ordinary speech no ordinary life but
buzz I hate to be but being sensible
about it I'm I don't having been this
careful for this long I don't
particularly want to go and stand in
Trafalgar Square and wave a flag it's
been very difficult what can I tell you
you know it's been very difficult though
it if you if you if you'd asked me three
years ago whether I'd either cracked up
by now I would have said well probably I
would somehow I have not cracked up I'm
unable to tell you perhaps you think I
have yes but it feels alright from here
and it's fault stop there
Salman most conspiracy shopper all right
my name is Robert Cox I now with the
post in Korean Charleston most
unexpected but very very welcome
my closest friend is Andrew granule was
the editor of index on Censorship and he
explained to me that when he heard that
you were in trouble he phoned you up and
said wouldn't you like to stay with us
in Golders Green until the trouble
class is over / yes the reason I bring
this up is that Andrews used to that he
left our Argentina some time before I
did and he wasn't killed because he left
Argentina hmm I think a person will help
people here to understand your situation
in the kind of things that happened in
Argentina the enormity of somebody being
killed or threatened immediately
suggested that they'd done something
that was enormously wrong and that
seemed to many people to justify it if
somebody was dead they deserved to be
dead if somebody was threatened with
death they that must have done something
terrible
seems to me that you've only written a
book have you done something else that
is terrible so that's what they asked
him in Argentina huh no I think thank
you I think that's true and I think that
connects back I mean if we look at that
history and you look at the the burnings
of heretics and the drownings of witches
no I mean large crowds would gather and
and would say oh they are terrible
people you know glad to get rid of them
and it is unfortunately one of the
problems of persecution it's like having
nasty things written about you in the
papers people believe them only it's
rather more extreme form of that no I
mean I just I just wrote this book and
it's very difficult to say this because
the Satanic Verses I mean I don't know I
will not I won't embarrass you by asking
for a show of hands which but I suspect
relatively few people in this room have
read the book many so rather more of you
may own a copy
but but there is a problem about this
book which is that it's been it's being
described that's to say the power to
describe it has fallen into the hands of
its enemies
I noticed when articles are written
about this issue in the British
newspapers they are written by Religious
Affairs correspondence how have I fallen
into the hands of Religious Affairs
correspondents yeah I think whatever
happened to literary editors and book
which I didn't like them but but
suddenly I'm a religious a fair and and
there's a there's a problem here which
is that people say that this is about
the I mean if you had asked somebody in
this room which again I went to bar
somebody to characterize the Satanic
Verses at about twenty or thirty words I
suspect people would think of it as very
serious heavyweight or arcane
theological dispute where the religion
that nobody knows anything about anyway
from somewhere else you know written by
somebody from somewhere else so what's
it got to do with us now but what's very
difficult to tell people is it actually
it's a comic novel that the entire
purpose of everything I've written the
attires of drive of my work is comic and
satirical that it's it's a story in
which those contentious passages are
heavily ionized are in heavily distanced
from any authorial position and occupy a
relatively small section of the text and
actually are not what the novel is about
now it's very hard when a book has been
so extensively falsified by such
powerful voices in so many countries to
keep on saying well actually it's not
like that it's a different book I didn't
write that book because people assume
that why would you know somebody stand
up in every pulpit of every mosque in
every country of the world where there
are mosques which is every country and
say a certain thing about a book if it
were not so and well the fact is it is
not so they are wrong about the book the
the kind of thick tshis demonized
Satanic Verses that exists in the in the
popular mind is no more the book that I
wrote than I am the fictitious demonized
person whose effigy is burnt in the
like square so it's very hard except to
keep saying that isn't me this is me
shaman thank you
the
thank you for your patience I'm sorry I
if I was rude to anyone it's more my
eyesight than rudeness but you chalk it
off either way the Solomon had to leave
to get his suit pressed as you can see
he's been spending too much time on
planes recently the answer to the
question regarding meetings was that
there was a meeting intended for
tomorrow on Capitol Hill there was some
pressure from the leadership to cancel
that meeting we don't know where that
came from
other than we were indication was it
came from the administration I would
hope that we would have more information
for you at some time in the near future
as you can imagine Solomon is not able
to stay in any one place for long and as
a result he'll be departing very shortly
I regret that we may not be able to
reschedule that meeting because these
things take weeks and weeks and months
and months having entered into his
bubble for one week I can only imagine
what it must be like to live there for
years and years and years I think it's
all it's clear to all of us that you
know in the very direct way that free
expression must remain free that Solomon
is us we are saman whether or not we
agree with what he's written we have to
appreciate what's happened to him for
what he's written I thank you for coming
from the leader the Democratic airship
and then in the same sentence you said
the administration I'm John them I don't
know a lot more we'll try and get you
more information tomorrow
fine optimization we do not have enough
information at this point were you were
you speaking of the Democratic
leadership yeah you said the leadership
yes then when you said the
administration you meant the White House
that's correct
this is at let's have this discussion
later want to turn the forum back to in
this particular matter as well I'm Chris
Wells vice president of international
operations for the Freedom Forum this
has been a very very important evening
an important evening for all of us who
have shared this commitment to free
expression and free speech we at the
Freedom Forum are especially pleased to
have been able to bring Solomon Roush to
here tonight to speak to us because he
is a symbol of what we have the freedom
forum support that is the fundamental
belief in Free Press free speech and
free spirit our work at the Freedom
Forum is to foster those beliefs and we
know that because of evenings like this
freedom works and we thank you for
sharing this evening with us
commencing now we might to to join us
for a reception outside this room and
also upstairs on the 23rd floor so we
can continue to express ourselves thank
you very much for coming thank you Chris
for some reason I beg you name is Carla
burgers